oh my god why did I do this first car
ever owned was a 1976 Monte Carlo it was
Burgundy had about five or six different
coats of clear on it metal flake I love
that car man I ate so many white
castle's in their car when I was a kid
my dream car is a 1957 Chevy Bel Air in
the year of 1957 that car was better
than any car you could ever buy a
convertible drop-top
Bel Air and you do know that yeah I
think the car that gets the most
attention from the ladies is my 1932
Ford Roadster man the girls scream over
the car is limeade on wheels baby the
next car I want to get in my collection
is a 1969 rolls-royce the bullet it's
the same kind and Michael Corleone wrote
in in The Godfather
if there's one car one celebrity that
I'm a little envious uh that's Flo Rida
he got that all gold but gaudy gold
everything I want to wake up in the car
with an uber got it I woke up a little
looper got it what's up ladies and gents
thanks for checking out my car
collection don't forget to subscribe to
GQ comm we have
[Music]